We were proud to sign on to the UN Sustainable
Development Goals.
For us goal number three is our north star:
“Good health and well-being.”
Every day our scientists are working to discover,
develop and bring to market medicines and
vaccines that help people live longer and
healthier lives.
And for us goal number three allowed us to
have a dialogue and an engagement with the
United Nations and with governments globally
to ensure that we’re partnering with them
to provide access to quality healthcare.
When we think about access to medicines we
think about a comprehensive strategy that
includes both donation and philanthropic support
as well as creative commercial strategies
designed to drive access to the most vulnerable
and under-served populations globally.
So for Pfizer we have a number of initiatives
that we’re very proud of.
One which I like to say is our oldie but goodie
was launched in 1998.
The International Trachoma Initiative was
launched to address a blinding disease called
trachoma.
At the time it was launched, we had a product
that treated active infection that causes
this disease.
And if the infection goes untreated over time
people do go blind.
And what we discovered was that our medicine
could treat this infection, but our medicine
was not sufficient: Alone that medicine would
not do the work that needed to be done at
a public health level.
For our work to address a blinding disease
called trachoma we’ve used a public health
strategy called SAFE.
SAFE stands for surgery – S, for advanced
cases of the disease.
A – the distribution of the antibiotic that
Pfizer makes to treat the active infection.
F which is face washing and E which is environmental
development.
Together that comprehensive initiative working
now with more than a hundred partners has
achieved elimination of this disease in six
countries.
That’s profound.
And it’s one of our greatest accomplishments
as a company.
It did not happen overnight.
It has taken more than two decades to achieve
that progress, but we have our eyes on the
prize which is full elimination of this disease
by the year 2020.
Another example where Pfizer is working to
meet the evolving global health needs is in
the area of oncology.
We have chemotherapy agents that are very
important for patients globally.
And we worked with our partners, the American
Cancer Society, the Clinton Health Access
Initiative, and CIPLA to make 11 prioritized
chemotherapy agents available in East Africa
where there is a disproportionate burden of
cancer.
We’re really proud of that initiative because
we’re taking some of our very important
core essential medicines and making them available
to reach more patients in areas of the world
that several years ago did not have this need.
So the business case for corporate responsibility
has been debated for years and there are different
perspectives on this.
I think for Pfizer and for the pharmaceutical
companies we can’t deliver our business
unless we deliver for society.Keeping that
patient that we serve front and center to
how we make the decisions that the company
takes every single day.
When we discover, develop and bring to market
medicines and vaccines that help people live
longer and healthier lives our communities
are healthier, society is healthier, and we
deliver both for our business and our shareholders,
but also for society.